welcome everybody to a special episode
of daytree podcast
a closer look a new series
that's like content court but not but
basically it's content core but we
didn't like how
rigid and strict it was with like a i in
and have to do charges and all this
so it's basically content core but
looser format
it's going to be called a closer look
and today we're going to be looking
closer at
the infamous mega
evangelical evangelist even
television television televangelist
not evangelical televangelist good luck
ethan
thank you keemstar i'm clearly gonna
need it
this episode is sponsored by liquid iv
thank you so much to them
um so you guys want to show off your
backgrounds a little bit
in honor so today we me and eli have
kenneth copeland as scrooge mcduck uh
jumping into a swimming pool of coins
um abu who you got there lucifer
lucifer that's apt ian's yours is kind
of
inspired kenneth has a power ranger what
do we got
the gates of heaven yeah he's like the
white ranger of god ah the white fire
ranger is like the
something more special about him though
he's got he's got a cool
uh uh vest he was the leader he was the
leader
absolutely yeah he's like the coolest
one i didn't know that
did you make that ian yes i did that
high level photoshop
design is my passion it reminds me of
the uh sword of good
guys jesus christ right
some of the stuff we'll watch a little
later kenneth kind of paints himself as
a bit of a power ranger type figure
little teaser for y'all i'm interested i
can't wait and zach yours is just
uh i got a big band kenny
big [ __ ] can you scoot to the side a
little bit has he got like a sax or
something
oh he's like oh frank sinatra kenny
kenny
he's such a versatile guy we have so
much i'm so excited because we
really i have to give i have to tip the
hat to these guys we have done
incredible amounts of research we are
bringing new and fascinating stuff we
are
exposing kind of like you have never
seen before
because i gotta tell you there is no
lower scum on earth
than a dude first of all who exploits
people
for money he's just down on their luck
big time he's lit he's a car he's a con
man you guys are going to see we're
going to show
we're going to prove allegedly he's very
rich don't assume me
so i'm i'm here jesus christ
yeah in minecraft
all right let's begin so you guys all
know
you know we've talked about kenneth a
lot so i'm just going to skim over the
background but
just to give you guys a little bit he's
worth 600
760 million bucks that's a lot of
blessings you know what i mean
up to that much but yeah it's very
likely
um he owns a mansion
obviously 33 acres of land that includes
a church
a warehouse a production studio a
boathouse and of course
an airport as all good men of christ do
here's his mansion here's airport you
can see a little bit from the air it's
kind of interesting to show you his
house
we rented this helicopter they had to
rent a helicopter to keep his property
valued at over 6 million he lives in
this home
outside fort worth texas it has
beautiful water views and comes complete
with the boathouse
but that's not all
copeland is an avid pilot and here's his
pride and joy
a 20 million dollar cessna citation jet
it's the fastest private jet money can
buy he said he needed it to better serve
the lord
oh yeah we need that for his followers
after the church
i love the
but driver not just one plane what's
with rich i feel like all
rich weirdos are pilots it's like one of
those past times
it's just you gotta it's like you made
so much money
and you're like what am i gonna do with
my time you can't do any play being
hobbies it's gotta be like i'm gonna fly
an airplane
you definitely need to spend more to get
that rush
because you can't just go buy a pair new
pair of shoes you need to like
you're like i need a new [ __ ]
airplane for 20 million dollars to get
that rush for buying something new
uh ab actually did a little bit of a
timeline here to give you guys the idea
of how
copeland's empire grew i think that's
pretty interesting so let's go ahead
and let a b tell the story all right
the history and scale of copeland's
empire in 1966 at nearly 30 years old
copeland decides to attend classes at
oral roberts university in tulsa
oklahoma
this is where copeland begins to learn
about the prosperity gospel
copeland ends up landing a job flying a
plane i'll tell you right now this is a
[ __ ]
look at how just this symbol whatever
this is
this is a call oral roberts university
cult
and look at this building like that
ain't of church i was gonna say what is
with the building that's a cold building
right but you know what i mean like i
don't know what to say but there's some
[ __ ] there's
some weird [ __ ] going on there um also
what's with this dude's name being oral
i'm just gonna like what's with his name
being oral can anybody uh
can we get some w's in the chat
for oral i mean what the [ __ ] who would
what's the deal with this guy
hey oral can i get some oral oral
roberts is sort of the godfather
um of this whole thing of
televangelism yeah yeah well his name's
oral
is that his real name i i mean i believe
so
it's like one of those old-timey names
and nobody says that sounds good as a
name
it's not right what that's like me
having a kid and naming him like uh
uh anal anal exactly ela
what am i gonna have a son and name him
anal
that's just ridiculous well said
copeland ends up landing a job flying a
plane for oral roberts the founder of
university earl roberts was a big deal
back in his day he's considered the
godfather prosperity gospel
i'll get more into the fundamentals of
prosperity gospel later on
after years of studying under oral
roberts kenneth copeland evangelist
association
later to become kenneth copeland
ministries was established in 1967.
the company grew a lot in the 70s in
1973 the first believer's voice of
victory newsletter was printed
in 1975 kcm launched its own radio
station
in 1976 kcm canada was established
in 1978 the first believers convention
was held in anaheim california in 1979
copeland began a weekly television
broadcast
also in 1979 kcm australia was
established in 1981
the first southwest believers convention
was held in 1982 kcm africa and casey
don't you feel bad he's like out there
even in africa fleecing like they have
so many problems like
bruh why you got to be out there like
he's like yo everything adds up
i just can't believe this guy does not
rest
every year there's like a new he's
grinding he's at that in that jet flying
that's like a big move every year
well it's easy to make big moves when
you don't pay a single [ __ ] cent in
taxes which we'll get to later
imagine if we did teddy fresh and didn't
pay a single [ __ ] cent in taxes
and we paid all of our employees like
eight dollars an hour yeah
i'd be making big moves every damn where
[Applause]
anyway dm europe was established in 1989
copeland began to produce a daily
television broadcast in 1994 kcm ukraine
was established
in 1996 an official website was launched
for kcm
in 2011 kcm asia is established in 2012
the first
hdbc that there are suckers everywhere
in the world
guest aired kcm roku channel debuts in
2014
kcm reached 1 million likes on facebook
in 2015 the ministry launched a
believer's voice of victory network with
24-hour programs
2019 the neighborhood believer's voice
of victory network was changed to
victory channel
and that pretty much brings us up to
modern day wow
nice well done av yeah well done try to
keep it short but it seems still kind of
long but
no it's good i mean it shows the guys
first of all
he's a hustler yeah i mean he's out
there in that jet he's [ __ ] zipping
around
he's in africa for christ's sake you
know what i mean
like that's a hustler bro
victory victory so
just here's some facts about his
ministry yada yada yada
yada yada yada
i mean it's just he's got a lot of
followers he's got a lot of fans i mean
you know he's only got 1.4 million subs
that's weak [ __ ] on facebook yeah here's
something that interested me he it goes
he has a podcast where is it
where's this [ __ ] podcast facts here
podcast has 3.8 million downloads since
inception in 2015. i'm like dude
i get that in like a week i mean where's
my billion dollars
i'm not i'm not monetizing properly
right um well where are you
offering you know nearly enough
you have channel memberships you know
you get some benefits for that early
access
just quite ten percent bro he's he's
offering access to heaven
yeah right right his his
value proposition is way better than
mine right can you read the part about
how many employees they have
oh they have uh 400 employees
in texas oh jesus
that's crazy they sell books magazines
dvds cds
yada yada you know his fans still buy
cds
translate in 22 languages people who
donate to kenneth
definitely buy cds
[Laughter]
translate into 22 different languages
you get the idea he's a big deal
so his whole thing is this idea of
prosperity
gospel which basically means that
when you give money to him he takes your
money on behalf of god
and you win god's good grace
in either finance or luck or whatever it
is that
basically whatever you want in your life
by giving
kenneth money you will basically
make more money just by the grace of god
that's so
um surprisingly convenient for him it's
awesome
he takes the money on behalf of god yeah
you
and most likely god will give it back to
you but like he doesn't have to do
anything
so what's really convenient is if if you
do not get good fortune
they we explain it later but it's your
fault if you're not
being faithful enough or you're not
you've done something wrong if you're
not
rewarded so it's nice like that it's
like the it's like putting money in the
stock market
it's like the god the god
the god they literally call it seed
money which is like similar
financial terminology like right you're
exceeding the money it's going to grow
into more
but you seed it by giving it to kenneth
what's the god at today
like the s p
the god is trading at like oh zero sucks
give you an idea of some of the videos
on this channel financial breakthrough
the laws of prosperity
finances faith and finances release your
faith in operating in god's
god's kingdom economy do you see that
that finances is a playlist
with 253 videos what oh wow oh my god
it's all everything he does is about
money everything he does is about money
kind of like tai lopez he's tai lopez
but like again he's got the best
proposition off forever
yeah he's the tai lopez of god yeah
knowledge basically his thing is
faith no knowledge like the opposite of
knowledge the ignorance he'll teach you
yeah the opposite of knowledge
so a lot of his money comes from this
idea called tithing which is when you
give 10
of all of the money you make to the
church
and him being the church he's happy to
take 10 of your paycheck
that's what tithing is he's there here's
one of the faqs on the website do i have
to tithe
the answer is a resounding yes this is
from the website
it is a cornerstone of real biblical uh
prosperity god's financial blessings are
reserved for the tither alone
that means if you do not tithe god will
not [ __ ] bless your ass
period i do love that it's one of the
frequently asked questions
yeah because they're like listen i want
to be involved but do i really have to
give you 10
of my money he's like yeah dude he's
like no you don't only if you want god's
blessings
so we've watched this clip a lot but i
do think it is important
to kind of punctuate this idea of
tithing
when coronavirus hit i think a lot of
people in the church were like i can't
afford to give you 10 right now i lost
my job
i'm behind on my rent my phone bill my
power yadda yadda
i just got you know i just got bailed
out by the government i just got 600
bucks
i can't afford to give you 60 dollars so
here's his response to them
and he's probably thinking of this well
i can't either
i have like half a million expenses just
on my jet yeah dude i pay i
just stole my anger you know how much it
cost to hang six jets
anyway here's his response to those
people coronavirus is
his faith in its ability to hurt you
kill you
uh the the the fear of
what are we gonna do i'm getting laid
off at work
hey your job's not your source
if it is you're in trouble
well they won't let us go to church well
email it in there
text give or something but you get your
tithe in that church
if you have to go take it down there and
drop it off and stick it under the door
or something
you get that tithe in that church you
get that offering in that church
and then you go home and you do what and
eat rhymes whatever your poor people do
amen so
right so you know yeah i don't
understand this whole thing
did i give people anything in return
you'll we get inspiration
empty promises we actually get into that
and i promise you
this gets so messed up i'm telling you
it really is incredible the amount of of
stuff you're going to see here today
i don't really understand this whole
thing god is our jesus is your source
your job is in your source yeah what are
you supposed to do if i give you a
hundred bucks am i supposed to just find
like 200
on the ground on the way home you know
what i mean i mean in some ways jesus
from what i've seen
yes actually exactly that um
they in some of the videos that i watch
they talk about how um
you know before i stop before i started
tithing i was really poor but once i
started doing it
uh sure enough a month later somebody
gave me a car
yes that's supposed to fix your life or
whatever you know what i mean like
it's just going to come to you like oh
my god that is more of a plan
yeah and then you're supposed to give 10
of that value back by the way
[Laughter]
so here's something here's something we
found out so
of course they have a 21 days to your
debt freedom dvd
you can buy this on their website for 25
dollars
as you know people who follow kenneth
are
they're looking they're looking for
financial freedom they're in debt these
are people who are having trouble with
finances like okay
how do i get out of debt wait wait i
just noticed
go back yeah i didn't i didn't realize
that second picture it's the
it's the notes you need the study notes
they sell that separately
oh it's 25 bucks for the dvd and then
another five bucks
come on can you just give a freebie so
you also have a cd on the website if you
want to listen to it in the car
what the [ __ ] is study notes just shut
up okay take your own notes
these guys know how to accessorize man
merchandise you guys are great it's
[ __ ]
you guys these guys believe in science
the science of
making money anyway so
i'm in debt i just spent thirty dollars
for the notes the dvds everything so
kenneth
please tell me how do i get out of that
mr george is back
and he's going to be talking to us about
how to live in the increase
and how to prosper and how to get our
return
it is imperative that you start out on
the first step of tithing
that is the foundation of prosperity i
can remember when we knew it was right
to tithe but we were so broke we just
didn't do it very well
that's right we would type and see how
we can
the lord could get along on it we would
tithe a few times and then we would let
it get behind
then we would try to catch up as long as
we did that we never enjoyed prosperity
but when we made a determination to
tithe
because it was in the word then we
walked in the blessings of god
tithing is the foundation to prosperity
and kenneth has taught this before that
he's [ __ ] kidding me
you paid 30 just for this [ __ ] to
tell you to make sure to tithe by the
way i believe that's his
son-in-law um yeah it's all in the
family
pretty much everybody that you see
speaking in any of these videos is
either
related by blood or marriage to kenneth
yeah that's his wife the other lady
there
right okay so um
so their answer to get out of debt is to
give kenneth
money right here's more eventually our
salary should become seed
there yeah in ephesians 4 28 let him
labor working with his hands the thing
which is good
that he may have to give to him that
needs so your salary should ultimately
be used
as seed to sow so this is an advanced
tip
so tithing is 10 he's saying listen give
us everything
that's how you get out of debt your
entire salary you know i don't
i don't know if that's actually what
he's saying he's saying give me your
salary
what is that he's saying a tithe from
your salary he's just he's just finding
another way to justify it with scripture
essentially
it's not funny just necessarily your
whole it does sound like he's saying
your whole salary right there but
to give him a benefit i don't think
you're saying 100 of your uh
why okay he's leaving it open look if
you want to give him like
he'll take it right well listen
by his logic the more you give the more
fun yeah you know you get
blessed he's like listen dude this the
return on this is so [ __ ] good the
more you put in
the better you get i mean it makes sense
it's like bitcoin to me
now this is day 331
we have 331 prosperity broadcasts that
we've done
and listen to this 1 million three
hundred and twenty three thousand
three hundred and twenty five outlines
have been downloaded
right of the prosperity broadcasting
isn't that exciting it really is
right but people have been so interested
in prospering
i am i know you are oh you're yes
i declare okay now ela this is when it
gets
really wild so
kenneth here has taken money from a lady
with terminal cancer
and has encouraged her that by s
sowing money giving them money that's
how that's her best path to
curing herself not traditional science
and you can probably guess that
despite her giving everything she's got
she just didn't do it right
this shit's crazy for more than 10 years
bonnie parker lived with the knowledge
that she was slowly dying of breast
cancer
but she told nobody of her fate no
doctors not even her own family
bonnie had turned instead to gloria and
kenneth copeland's ministry
bvov for her healing sickness disease
and pain
i resist you in jesus name
you are not the will of god
i enforce the word of god on you
my days of sickness and disease are over
honestly believe that if she would not
have gotten
involved with these people the chance of
her being here today
is is very very great i started finding
notebooks
it's her daughter how long have she
passed away these notebooks they went
back to 1995.
and when i first found them i didn't
know i didn't know who
bbov was i'd heard of kenneth copeland
i've heard of gloria copeland
but not be vov and on top of these
was bvov and then the more i read
it's just it was like reading
from someone i had no idea in the world
who was writing
but it was her handwriting and she did
write them
and it went back to telling exactly
what her life was like bonnie's
notebooks describe in detail
just how closely she hung on to the
copeland's promises for her healing
mom had asked me um before she passed
away
if i would carry her too i think it was
here in dallas texas to one of her
um her schools or whatever and of course
you know then i was furious or she
wouldn't go to the doctor but she would
join me take her this healing school
cancers of the devil
cancers of the devil sickness and
diseases of the devil
of the devil you take healing scriptures
like you take
natural medicine except it'll do you
good
all the time and you you don't have to
die from the side effects
she would purchase powerball tickets
i want to go to this healing part that
she believed and i know she believed
because it's in the notebooks
that if she sowed enough seed which was
money
um the the greater amount of seed that
you sow
according to them um the better chance
you have
the better chance you have of getting
healed right she
asked the lord in these prayers
in these to let her win the powerball
and it says in there that if he would
permit that
that she would donate you know she would
donate it to
um she says her church family which is
the baby of v and i honestly believe
with all my heart and soul
that's what she thought that i guess the
amount of money that she was
buying powerball tickets so that she
could win and donate it to the church
so that because it gives more money the
more healing she gets right
so she was too poor to get the healing
she needed
buy her her healing and it's so
upsetting because especially
with cancer i experienced it obviously
with my dad so
i've seen how the what
the hospitals and the treatment
treatments offer you
um is like so depressing and it's not
really
necessarily going to help you you don't
know
so i've seen how desperate you can get
you know
and you're you're really desperate for
anything and um
that's so [ __ ] up that they're using
people at that stage
it's it's the most [ __ ] that if you are
going to take money
from people with cancer with the promise
yeah there's just there's no
lower form of making money no that is
evil just plain and simple there there's
just no lower form
of getting money i think this really
just
this is i think this really just shows
who they are notebooks
anything and and she was actually asking
god in these notebooks to let her win
for them christie wrote two letters to
kenneth and gloria copeland asking about
her mother's involvement with their
ministry
all i wanted was just for them to tell
me
or to have the decency maybe to tell me
what happened or just
say okay you know your mom was with us
for all these years we're so sorry you
know
i feel that if they don't didn't feel
guilty about what happened why
why at least didn't they pick up the
phone and call me after all
me tell nothing nothing
and i just i feel that you know if they
were the good christian people that they
say they are that i at least i would
have deserved an answer
if not me my family christy wanted to
visit the copeland ministry headquarters
and asked for answers directly
so we did just that at the copeland
headquarters we were met by this lady
who offered to take us on a tour of the
buildings
she explained that the copelands
personally owned the cattle ranch
more than 50 gas wells and pump more
than 10 million dollars of oil annually
all of which are located on the 1500
acre ministry property
when we reached the mail room we asked
the copeland's representative why some
letters like christie's were not
responded
[Music]
son of kenneth and gloria and you
guessed it chief executive
chief executive who bluntly declined an
interview with us
obviously you know up to something
that's not good in our benefit
so am i going to do an interview i asked
him whether there was anything that the
copelands might have said
that would have caused bonnie parker to
refuse medical attention
you know i can't answer for her
when her mother was sick and why she
didn't tell her daughter or anything i
had no idea about it
i mean i guess her mother has her own
reasons it's not we don't believe in
doctors
we certainly believe in doctors you do
absolutely generally doctor what never
said don't go to a doctor
i don't think you'll ever read a letter
says you know we guarantee you're gonna
be ill
first thing you know you'll be on drugs
and then then it'll be bad
you know prescription drugs or drugs
and they alter your your thinking and
you don't want that you want to alter
your thinking yourself with the word of
god
it's awesome they alter your thinking to
the doctor
well this is god's medicine this is
better than anything man could make up
because
a lot of times the medicine you take
makes you sick in another way
the bad news is we don't know what to do
about it
except give you some poison that'll make
you sicker
not everybody receives their healing
till her last breath
she had faith she never
i don't think never gave up as far as
that i
the disappointment was great i mean she
you could tell she was just very very
disappointed
that what she had been asking for
never came i then asked copeland junior
why he thought that so many people like
bonnie parker did not receive their
healing
when they were in fact people of such
deep faith that they sent their last
pennies to copeland ministries
and even went to the extreme of refusing
medical treatment well i think there
could be a lot of reasons
well what do you think what do you think
they are i guess you know
a person could have unforgiveness in
their heart towards somebody which can
hinder your faith
i don't
well i don't understand why god healed
him and he won't heal me
here he's here he's clowning on her
basically
by some stretch
of the imagination
oh probably not but could it be
that is your fault not god
[Laughter]
oh yeah say it oh yeah
say it well you know i've just done
everything i just i love how for more
than 10 years
i love how like god is so infallible but
yet like
there's it's always like your fault and
not god's like bro if he's so [ __ ]
powerful
why do we need all these rules and
[ __ ] tricks and [ __ ] but also this
guy just has the most convenient
position in the world like
if anything doesn't happen as he says
he's like well that's what god decided
to say it's your future probably listen
you didn't you didn't pray right
yeah you know these people these people
are psychopaths yeah
and i love like why would you even go
look why didn't god heal
me but he healed them
look get a load of this idiot
oh probably not but could it it's got
like a whole stand up
yeah i know good timing and [ __ ] that is
your fault
not god
oh yeah say it say it oh
yeah oh yeah like the kool-aid
[Music]
we found this flyer by gloria copeland
explaining the reasons why her followers
may not receive their promised healing
good so that was long but i felt like
so compelling i wanted to watch the
whole thing um
yeah that's as bad as again yeah that's
pretty much it
so let's throw it to um a commercial and
when we come back
we are still just the tip of the iceberg
of the
copeland
the copeland crime family
ah i like that the copeland crime family
that's dan's words not mine
that'd be so funny if they sued dan only
i'd be like look sorry dan i act
bankruptcy is the only option i can't
help you
all right let's throw a quick break
we'll come back and talk about the
copeland crime family as
dan has labeled them
liquid iv is the great new product to
keep you
hydrated energized and your
metabolism and your uh
immunity boost it go ahead and say it
with me
liquid iv with one stick of liquid iv
and 16 ounces of water you get two to
three times the amount of hydration as
plain water
oh really i'll be the judge of that
comes like this you just put it in the
water right
oh [ __ ] i put it all over the [ __ ]
table you get the idea
stir it up you know how to stir [ __ ]
cheers
being electrolyzed bro i feel like i
just drank a whole [ __ ] ocean
[Music]
[Music]
oh
liquid iv has incredible hydrating
flavors like watermelon
lemon lime and passion fruit and they
recently launched strawberry
imagine ila if you will a freshly picked
taste of ripe
juicy strawberries topped with a
decanted note
of whipped cream what amazing
this flavor is um which flavor is this
watermelon tastes great i love it
you smell it so
um liquid iv as i uh it contains five
essential vitamins
more vitamin c than an orange and more
potassium than a banana
it's healthier than sugary sports drinks
no artificial flavors are preservative
and less sugar than an apple it's made
with clean
ingredients non-gmo vegan and free of
gluten dairy and soy
what makes liquid iv so effective
it's got the optimal ratio of glucose
sodium and potassium
delivering water and nutrients right
into your bloodstream
it's the perfect balance to help you
hydrate more quickly and effectively
than water alone
one stick of liquid iv and 16 ounces of
water can give you as much hydration as
two or three bottles of plain water
their mission is to change the world
they donate they have donated 3.7
million servings in response to kova 19.
products are being donated to hospitals
first responders food banks veterans
and active military they've donated over
6.7 million service
because it's like super hydration you
know it's like a liquid iv that's good
like they say it's got all the minerals
the electrolytes all that you know all
that [ __ ]
[Music]
oh it's beams coming in my eyes that's
how i feel like
you know grab your strawberry liquid iv
or other great flavors
in bulk nationwide at costco or you can
get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
the code h3 at checkout
that's 25 off anything you order when
you use code h3 liquid iv.com
get better hydration today at liquid
iv.com code h3 you know i want to say
also
this is the hydration one but they have
a caffeine one that like sometimes i
don't feel like drinking coffee and it
[ __ ] up my stomach because it's acidic
it's sometimes i just want to game and
get all
jazzed up or work or whatever so like
they have the um caffeine one which i
don't have here but it's like the orange
one i don't know what flavor it is
but um that's a great way to start your
day because you get no glass of water
you getting the caffeine you need so
i love liquid iv i use it i recommend it
i think it's awesome
you know so there you go
that's the plug liquid com
promo code h3 25 off everything
how did you like um that little cancer
story ela
it's actually really upsetting yeah yeah
and this is just one dude who's like an
investigative journalist who happened to
find this story
you know that was a good yeah good
uh edited piece yeah
you unfortunately you just can't touch
these people they're just they're
invincible
like jeffree star well it's kind of like
also in a cult
people are willingly participating so
right it's always tricky
so uh moving on uh we are getting
into uh the elite group of
alpha suckers called the elite c isn't
cx the
pus
was is cx team
that's hilarious so to join the elite
group of alpha suckers all you need to
do is pledge seventeen hundred dollars
and like all good colts the top tier
suckers are given an article of
recognition so they get a badge you see
this [ __ ] on there
that's culture right there with a badge
literally all you have to do to earn
this is donate money like oh my god
so for net here's nexium scarves for
comparison so yeah
the badges really good yeah
many here's an excerpt from their
website many of
many of you made commitments to mission
three to acquire a second citizen
citation x a number of you have already
completed or sewn beyond the initial
1700 pledge we are grateful to god for
your support
we we believe that as funds continue to
come in
we will have what we need to purchase
the gulf stream 5.
we encourage you to continue to believe
in our god meets all your needs
according to his riches and glory jesus
name
so basically they're saying give us
money because we are fundraising to buy
this gulf stream
five what is that that's an airplane
it's like a luxury
private jet a really large one
yeah it's super nice super expensive
so there you go more elite cx team
oh so they had a first mission seed sewn
baby
2016 they got this jet mission two
they got a high definition truck
congratulations elite team
mission three this was the epic one
gulfstream five let's go
mission three god told copeland he needs
a bigger plane
so copeland ended up buying one from
tyler perry
the the listing price of a new gulf
stream five is currently 61.5 million
the average asking price for one built
in the year he bought is ranges between
it's about 20 million bucks
that wasn't i go back yeah
exactly it's all i like that it's uh
a mission it's the elite mission
come on baby join the club and help me
buy a bigger jet it's crazy
it's just awesome now it's so open and
he gives them badges and [ __ ] it's just
it's just amazing so he said about this
we continue to pray
standing and believing for god's wisdom
in the situation and on february 1st at
11 a.m
the lord spoke to brother kenneth saying
you're believing for the wrong airplane
the citation x is too small you have
already outgrown it the second citation
x will come but at a later date
your your current airplane is so last
season
you really should be upgrading god said
by the way don't forget that
when somebody asks kenneth why doesn't
he fly coach he famously said
i don't want to be on a tube with a
bunch of demons
yeah it's awesome
so moving on to the irs has actually had
some intercount
encounters with copeland's church
actually no that's not true here here we
kind of go over how is
all of his earnings tax exempt how do
what do we know about the money he makes
and etc etc
so he is technically obviously you know
designated as a church which means that
it's a non-profit
organization and you're given broad
exemptions over taxation
and regulations um
okay i mean we all know that it's
america separation yadda yadda
so that's meaning that his church kcm is
a nonprofit
copeland can take millions from his
followers and he doesn't have to account
for the money they receive
at all that means that copeland is not
legally obligated to disclose how much
money he ends up in his pocket he
doesn't have to show or explain
anything doesn't he have to disclose
they don't have to explain
a single [ __ ] thing oh
and we think that you would have because
it's the nonprofit so it's
actually well it's a church
too it's more than a number it's a super
non-profit
it's a super non-profit for profit
kcm is also listed as a church which
means they follow the same tax
guidelines and regulations that small
town churches follow it's not
it doesn't make sense that a big that
this church here
you know what i mean would have to
follow the same tax guidelines as this
one here
it's just a different scale entirely but
there you go
right because the purpose of these
exemptions are for these you know small
churches who
can't afford to provide basic things
within the church
yeah and i think the idea too is that
you
you use the money for social services
and taking care of people and all this
like
you know but as you'll find out well
i'll talk about that later but
his his whole mansion estate is also
exempt from
property tax what this [ __ ]
doesn't even have to
pay property tax because technically his
house
is listed as a parsonage a parsonage is
a tax
uh issue let's see the person's
exclusion has two
aspects if a church provides a house for
a minister of the gospel to live in
the fair market value of in-kind housing
is exempt
and then also the second part is cash
housing allowances paid in lieu
of in-kind housing are also exempt from
income tax
there is no dollar limit from any of
these
tax-free housing allowances to t
televangelists
and mega church pastors can and do run
in the hundreds of thousands per month
crazy right there's no
there's no limit
okay now this is great ministry watch is
an
independent evangelical organization
that raised the financial accountability
of different
churches kcm kenneth's church
received an f
okay ministry what does anyone do about
that
well they're just trying to inform
people but ministry watch explains
ministry watch uh profiles public
charities
churches and para church ministries
ministry watches
yada yada yada they said
um oh this is about okay yeah so here
here here's what they said about him
kenneth copeland ministries has chosen
not to be open and transparent with
ministry watch
as such it is difficult to understand
all aspects
of its ministry prudent donors want to
understand
what it is they are going to support
some ministries claim they have no legal
obligation to share financial
other information but they do have a
moral obligation to do so
christians should have nothing to fear
by being open
all will be judged at a future date and
with this thought in mind
how are we to conduct ourselves before
god today
organizations described as christian
ministers are at least giving people an
image of god
is god characterized as closed impartial
and hidden
or open personable and knowledgeable
scripture
enjoins christians to conduct themselves
honestly so they're
using the crips they're basically using
the bible to slam dunk on him
the first card victory victory
so here we brought some receipts from
the bible
because they argue they have this whole
idea of um
you know prosperity he even said jesus
would be wearing a rolex
they just haven't been invented yet
which by the way
that's that's just you how could you
[ __ ] claim that the dude cruised
around and like
didn't he famously just claim cruise
around like uh loin
cloth and [ __ ] you know what i mean they
had nice clothes back then
you think that the emperor just cruised
around the same [ __ ]
blanket as everybody else he had like
pimp ass jewelry and [ __ ]
you know so i've always heard from my
mom
who grew up very like religious that
it's it's a lot about like modesty and
being
that was what jesus was all about so i
was
i was going to say i don't know if it's
any different because obviously we're in
israel
studying the jewish way but i feel like
it would be the same
yeah i mean a lot of so let me read you
some verses
from the bible because jesus was not
about rich people jesus did not like
rich people
he said here treasures gained by
wickedness do not profit but
righteousness delivers from death
you shall not steal obviously don't
steal it you're just saying
you're claiming he's stealing stuff
maybe he's just stealing money from
people
for the here's another one for the love
of money is the root of all kinds of
evil
it is through this craving that some
have wandered away from
faith and pierce themselves with many
pains
yeah man that sounds more like stuff
that i know jesus said
if you want to be perfect go sell your
possessions and give it to the poor
you will have the treasures in heaven
then come follow me
kenneth are you reading this i mean that
makes sense to me like if you want to
teach about giving
and if you want donations then like go
give it to a poor person exactly
well jesus's whole life was about
sacrificing everything right that's the
story of jesus i sacrificed everything
for you
including my own life so he's just like
such a loophole that it all ends up
going to one person with no transparency
at all
yeah jesus said to his disciples truly i
tell you
it is hard for someone who is rich to
enter the kingdom of heaven
again i tell you it is easier for a
camel to go through the eye of a needle
than someone who is rich to enter the
kingdom of god
kenneth is like man [ __ ] that guy
ignore that wasn't the chalice of the
carpenter not gold
wasn't it just plain good points
and i wonder if he's seen uh indiana
jones as well
a good point though jesus points out
that money and god
are rivaling masters if you love money
you will despise god
he says you cannot serve both god and
money
who put this together amy that was a b
yeah it's nice
exactly it's like slam dunk [ __ ] your
shit's [ __ ] phony
jesus hates your ass my grandfather was
actually a pastor on my mom's side
oh really oh yeah you've got all kinds
of flavors of god in you
so what would they think about someone
like copeland oh yeah they would
definitely you know they would they
think it's the worst yeah i i can't
imagine what my mom would think
i think i think i would assume that
anyone
or most people who follow traditional
religion would think he's just a con man
i mean he's really not
yeah we should make it clear that um
this is not all christians
by any means this this is a very
specific uh
kind of uh thread of evangelical
evangelicalism right in america that
this whole prosperity gospel thing this
is i mean it's really
it's just an america he's he's well he's
global you're right he's in africa bro
ukraine the ministry watch because you
know that's a christian
organization you know talking about
they're even slam dunking on them
he's just a con man i don't even think
he's religious i just can't believe
that it's resonating with so many people
then it's like any cult
yeah they just want to believe you know
i mean
you've got a couple excerpts there but i
think you've you might have forgotten
one
the thou shall get this bread
are you sure they're not just talking
about is that king james
yeah i think it is i thought it was
saint kanye
i think it's actually it's it's from the
book of get a joke
wow yeah oh thank you
wow yeah i would buy
that lesson from uh ian
that was good what version of the bible
is that
i'm not sure which one that is uh you
should sell some cds ian
yeah 25.99 and how much for the foot for
the study notes
well that's going to be 26.99
it's worth it it's worth it
yeah you know and he found out this
perfect little loophole because it's
like
okay how do i do the best con i do a con
that's a religion and i don't even have
to pay taxes
yeah that's what scientology did too
it's awesome
i would love to see like a full-on
documentary
of someone trying to expose this like
i'd fund it like they did with uh nexium
and
the guy i would fund the [ __ ] out of
this if any documentaries out there
hit me up i'll fund it how much does it
cost to fund an independent documentary
a lot well let's talk
i think i can get you there i can get
you close we'll give you a shout out
now come on i want to fund it i want to
fund it and we can figure it out
this is the beginning of a big beautiful
new vertical for us
so okay so copeland receives huge
amounts of cash donations
by believers in the mail along with the
written prayer requests
which don't get seen by copeland okay so
former
employees have spoken out against
copeland here is one such example
from former employees who tell news 8
the kenneth and gloria copeland you see
on tv
glory to god are not the kenneth and
gloria
of real life we were treated like galley
slaves
oh in my eyes there's deception there's
a
fear mentality placed on people that
work there
just three former copeland ministry
employees speaking out about the
disappointment
discovering what really goes on inside i
started going to church there in 1994.
among them jeff spradlin who says he
grew up admiring the copelands and was
excited to get a job working for them
within 90 days i started realizing this
was a huge mistake
for nearly two years bradley worked in
the mail processing center where prayer
request envelopes
stuffed with cash would arrive every
morning he says a group of ministers
not the copelands would pray over the
unopened envelopes
but spradling says he and other male
processors were the only ones who
actually
read the requests because he's saying
they're getting this nobody even read
the [ __ ] prayers
they just took the money and like
basically threw that [ __ ] out
and going kent and gloria don't see a
word of this
how many of these prayer requests to
your knowledge
do kenneth and gloria copeland see and
or
pray over none but i know
this former employee also processed
prayer requests and sent return letters
crafted to give the look of a personal
response oh my gosh
they wrote it as ken that's wow you know
what's interesting is all this exposed
stuff is like
really old so i think a new one could be
so powerful
hbo please i feel like this is even more
interesting than
nexium i guess they like the whole
sexual weird stuff but like
he's so evil yeah but at the end what
really gets them is like the
tax fraud and the right
because nexium you can't really even
claims religious
these guys have so much shielding so
here
if you go to like glass door and indeed
and where all these people can leave
reviews
so these are past employees who have
left reviews about working for the
minister
oh he's the pro is
i got to learn about church the con is
if
it's a ministry you work full time and
get told
they tell you that kcm is not your
source when you ask for a raise
no [ __ ] way i bet you they they they
expect these people who they pay to
give the money back to them oh my god
wow here's another one leadership
dysfunction overall the leadership of
kcm is oblivious to the damage they
inflict on the staff daily
no no accountability from the top down
ministry family priority priorities
always come first
and personality-based organization is
impossible to execute
best business practices in any way high
stress low market pay and possible
workload
wow kcm is a great place to work for
those used
to doing what is told to them and not
having ideas to save money
con is you get fired if you see it as
just a job
it has to be a calling so you will put
up and shut up
i worked at kcm for years during my time
there i learned the following
maybe a christian workplace but keep
your head down there's absolutely no
loyalty to the employees
no matter how long you have served as
they put it scandals get squashed
unless you are a minion unless you are a
minion then you get to move
on to the next phase of your ministry
fired i was released because i exercised
my free right to drink a beer
at my home not at work off the clock and
someone turned me in
what it is sad to see the cult that kcm
is becoming it used to be a highly
respected ministry doing great things
if you are a career minded if you are
looking for longevity and a job keep
looking
the more money you make the more you are
overhead
to the overall financial plan dead end
turn back
don't say i didn't warn you wow all you
have to do is look at the emblem
the church uses at eagle mountain
international church
it sums it up it's a big bird puking
into the mouth of a little bird and the
little bird better swallow
yeah that's crazy so they don't reward
anyone who's been with them because they
want to keep low salaries
well everyone who runs it's in the
family you know what i mean
so everyone else is expendable
so the senate and 2017 actually did a
huge investigation
into his organization 2007 2007 what do
you say
so a senator chuck grazely and a
financial
what grass the grass is always green
early
chuck grassley and a finance committee
investigated the mega church
the investigation looked into the use of
church-owned airplanes homes and credit
cards by pastors
the lack of financial oversight from the
ministry board was also looked into it
was discovered that the majority of
kcm's
board is copeland's family members and
friends
all things are possible with god
including his wife
his son his son-in-law
sister-in-law so they noted that
kcm did not agree to cooperate with the
committee
but the committee still filed its report
based on public records in third parties
in the report several former employees
of kcm indicated that kcm used
intimidation
in an attempt to keep informants from
talking to the committee
there's probably a lot of dirt oh my god
they said it's clear that kcm did not
intend to cooperate with the committee's
request and provided the missing
responses as a result committee staff
attempted to secure the requested
information from public records and
third parties
in this process staff learned that kcm
used
strong tactics to prevent former
employees from speaking about the
organization
even to committee staff several former
employees
indicated that they used intimidation
and an attempt to keep informants from
speaking
former employees were sincerely afraid
to provide statements for fear of being
sued
since they signed confidentiality
agreements employees were
contacted by kcm attorneys after the
initiation of the committee
investigation
and reminded that they signed a
confidentiality agreement agreeing not
to disclose any information
one former employee stated the following
the copeland employee
guerrilla tactics to keep their
employees silent we are flat out told
and threatened that if we talk god will
blight our finances
strike our families down and pretty much
afflict us with everything evil and
unholy
rather god will allow satan to do those
things to us because we have
stepped out from under his umbrella of
protection
wow by touching god's anointed prophet
further employees are encouraged to shun
and treat badly anyone who dares to
speak out
that's [ __ ] that you like that typical
cold behavior 100 cult baby it's
literally just using
the the the the you know
christianity as a as a cover but it's
it's
it's it's the same exact thing that you
know scientology does
pretty much um
so more from the senate investigation
they investigated the minister the use
of ministry
jets apparently they have five aircrafts
in connection with its tax exempt
religious purpose
you like that i love it a former
minister
stated that gloria copeland used a jet
to fly to naples florida to go shopping
she would purchase clothing sculptures
and home furnishings
john copeland a ministry employee
and some others used a jet to go on
hunting trips
we love it kenneth copeland used to
travel back and forth to arkansas to see
a chiropractor
love it the copeland family also flew to
colorado to visit their home
and steamboat springs from time to time
that doesn't sound like ministry
purposes
as trisha would say they sound very
bougie yeah that's boujou that is bougie
let's take the private plane down to uh
the chiropractor and uh
colorado he's my fave oh my god
an insider states that copeland no
longer receives a salary
glory oh sorry strike that gloria
copeland last known salary was 400
000 and that was in the early 2000s
kenneth and gloria both receive
honorariums
which they go to speak at churches
conventions and crusades that are not
crusades that doesn't sound good
the normal amount received by each is 10
000 and they
are at times will also receive a
percentage of the offering collected by
sponsoring church
they get a percentage of crazy on the
crusade that
that's when they talk [ __ ] about
everyone that complains right that's our
crusade
um there's a whole lot but these guys
are sketchy as [ __ ]
crazy um
here he is trying to we again we've seen
this but it's just it's a perfect
punctuation
a reporter basically blitz copeland
and asked him about his comment about
demons on a tube
also asked about his luxury lifestyle
copeland responds that it is wealthy man
and
responds that he's a wealthy man and
says not all of his money is from
offerings well
what else but anyway he's here he is
justifying his use of a private
five private jets in fact how are you
sir
we'd just like to ask you about why you
don't want to fly commercial
why have you said that you won't fly
commercial you said that it's like
getting into a tube with a bunch of
demons
why do you think that no listen to me
just singing
not the people the main reason
is because of the need if
if i flew commercial you'll foster their
ability to stop 65
of what i'm doing that's really to me
isn't it true that you want to fly
commercials so that you can fly in
luxury
how much money did you pay for tyler
perry's gulfstream jet for example
well for example that's really none of
your business but
the business of your donors she's great
i paid
you kind of caught me off guard here
okay
now thank you lord help me just
let me pray again getting back to the
comment you said that you don't like to
fly commercial because you don't want to
get into a tube with a bunch of demons
do you really believe that human beings
are demons no i do not
and don't you ever say i did get in an
air get in a long tube with a bunch of
demons
bro he's so angry we wrestle not
with flesh and blood but principalities
and powers
can you explain what you meant by that
yeah
well let me ask you do you think that
people that fly commercial or demons
give me a chance to talk sweetheart i'll
explain this to you
but it's a biblical thing it's a
spiritual thing it doesn't have anything
to do with people
what is it and he still didn't
understand i spent a lot of time
on airlines but the main thing that
happened was not that wasn't the main
reason the main reason he doesn't blink
he looks like he's that shoe nice like
dead eyes
no longer do what uh why doesn't he
blink call to do
and be on there he hasn't blinked just
look at him and close when i get there
and so and you have some fancy clothes i
mean he hasn't blinked yet
i'm just watching a life of luxury
you've got great homes you've got great
planes
you do you drive in limos
my wealth doesn't come from offerings
alone
okay but mostly so sell things books and
dvds yes
and i have a lot of natural gas on our
property right
didn't know that did you baby now i do
yeah you do
isn't that wonderful well i guess well
i'm pretty sure i'm pretty sure you
didn't buy that massive estate
shut up yeah how would you buy that
exactly please dude
you don't mind that much gas bro okay so
again there's just there's so much it's
crazy it's never ending with this guy
this story is so crazy the angel
flight 44 controversy
okay sounds pretty ridiculous right yeah
a true story
written by these two goons after
hurricane katrina
copeland's friend who owned a cargo jet
wanted assistance flying medical
supplies into the area
kenneth offered some financial help and
afterwards decided to start an entire
ministry devoted to this
sounds good right it was called angel
flight 44
with the intent to fly supplies to
natural disaster zones
nice kenneth even commissioned a book
about the ordeal to promote his new
ministry
all the while asking for donations to
fund the angel
flight 44. uh-oh i love the idea sounds
great
yet after months of donations the angel
flight 44 ministry was disbanded
they never sent aid to another disaster
again
no hangers were ever built no additional
airplanes were ever purchased
and the donation money was never
accounted for
kenneth copeland ministries spokesman dr
steven
swisher told the christian post this was
not a specific promise with a timeline
attached according to switcher
angelflight 44 has collected only
7 700 and the donations were spent on
plane repairs
even the author of angelflight 44 book
has turned on copeland regarding the
situation
believing that the ministry was never
created the author of the book
said while there is a huge crisis going
on in the nation of
haiti right now kenneth copeland
promised angel flight 44 ministry
is nowhere to be found and the money he
collected to start that ministry
has not been accounted for it is as if
kenneth copeland had never
said such a ministry had already been
formed nor had repeatedly promised that
such an
aviation support ministry would be
further developed and ready
for disasters as such as that which just
occurred in
haiti a few days ago so did he ever help
at all i didn't
sounds like not wow he just pocketed the
money and forgot it ever happened
crazy right
shameless okay you want to see shameless
here he is
healing somebody is this the person with
um down syndrome or
i believe so yeah i don't think it's
specifically said but
oh so here here he is here's kenneth
copeland healing somebody with down
syndrome
so that sounds legit yes why thank you
that she
is healed and made whole and everything
in this body
i speak
in stop
i demand a recount just to hear him say
chromosomes
he said i demand the proper number of
chromosomes
bro it's a little late for that proper
count
and i demand
the proper count you can't do that
right it doesn't work like that kenneth
copeland you can't just
do that i demand the proper
count of chromosomes how many are we
supposed to have
22 or something like that how many
chromosomes are we supposed to have now
anyone know that's can i get a count
please can i get a recount on the
chromosomes
absolutely insanity nobody got an answer
on the problem
it's 46. we i demand 46 chromosomes be
gone 47th chromosome i
strike you down with holy
scalpel carve out that extra chromosome
now you stop that fear
i demand a recount god it's a little
late for fixing the chromosomes bro
god kind of already [ __ ] that one up
if i can be
or not i mean you know they're beautiful
they're all beautiful children
i'm just all right just saying it's a
little late it's like you can't
once you've got the cake baked you can't
be like oh i i demand less sugar god
you've got to go back to when you mix
the cake
i demand one gram of sugar out this cake
god
it's just a little too much it's a
little too sweet
amen
amen proper order
proper count proper count recount
thank you stop the con and i agree
also by the way how bad do you feel for
this poor girl who's like
they're making her feel like a monster i
demand you god
take this demon take this demon 47
chromosome out
watch that thing for the redeeming of
her time
that has been stolen from her
it's not she's stolen from her out the
rest of her days
in
bro jesus fact that he actually just did
that is so [ __ ] crazy
i demand a recount on the chromosomes
god
and there's more too here he does
another miracle on a
what's the proper way to say uh develop
mentally intellectually disabled is the
problem
the intellectually disabled thank you oh
yes oh yes oh there's someone on the
ground jesus let's
let's help her up first yes
she's free we call her free in jesus
name and healed
everything about glory to god no
no y'all know this ain't gonna work you
come back every week and
it doesn't work glory glory hope by the
power of the living
stop jesus is our healer
amen thank you so much thank you jesus
glory just tapped around all right
you're all good
be loose you're all good now be normal
be normal he's not working
jesus be normal we call him he'll
what he gave
well the other girl she'd be in order to
banish a chromosome
thank you that's a miracle thank you
it seems like he's feeling better oh
yeah i feel like he's he's feeling
better hey
man jesus hey hey uh
who should i do this to ian i command
you to be
normal sorry i just had to pick somebody
to do it too
i think you're normal i think you're
great i just had to do it to somebody i
command you ian to cast out the extra
chromosome
well right now cast it out right now
okay i'll get i'll get on there right
now get ready i'm command you zap that
anyway watch that demon die i think
i don't actually think you're abnormal
or anything i just i wanted to do the
joke and i wasn't sure
yeah yeah i know i should have done it
to keemstar here let me redo it i'm
sorry
keemstar i demand you be normal in the
name of jesus
keemstar i demand an extra cr i demand
get rid of that extra chromosome amen
i pray for you hypocritical thank you
jesus
why is it his hand is so what is a great
one this is all just his stunts now i
don't know
in 2020 and covet he tried to banish
covet i mean guys it clearly didn't work
this was in march 2020.
we are out here with 400 000 people dead
and like why is nobody
questioning the the virility the
veracity of his [ __ ]
did it work look at his wet ass hand
maybe those people didn't tithe put your
hand on all right
oh
you better get that diving in you know
the guy
and wuhan they weren't tied i think so
god was like
damn you know um
you know wet ass [ __ ] wet at sam um
just trying something
thank you lord jesus
it looks like he was just like fisting
somebody healing yeah i mean
it's all gooey and [ __ ] gross
why is it so gooey like it's not water
yeah no it looks gooeier than water
it's mine i think it's holy lube oh my
god
kenneth copeland jelly black
blessed by god it always sounds like
kirkland
copeland according to the word of god
according to the word i'm healed
yes and i consider not my own body
yes it continues not my own body i
consider not i love these guys in the
background
but only that which god has promised
only that what the word has said oh
and by his stripes i was healed
and by his stripes i am healed now
i'm not the sick trying to get him blah
blah blah shut the [ __ ] up
dumbass con man gooey ass hand
here he is passing more judgment on
cover 19 with his son-in-law
judgment right now because we are in the
name of jesus oh thank you
oh he's like whoa whoa whoa you got to
give me a heads up before you do that
he cut him off because
what do you want to have for dinner in
the name of jesus
i'm going to cut you off from now on oh
[ __ ] okay we're doing that
i execute judgment on you covet 19.
okay he didn't pray hard
you enough me some you know what i think
i think his ass hasn't been tithing
enough
who does he tithe to right who the [ __ ]
do you tithe to
kenneth bitch-ass copeland do you bury
money in your yard or some [ __ ] like i'd
like to know who the [ __ ] he's tithing
to
anal roberts oh to anal
do you think that lube was for anal on
his hand
or i mean oral sorry i mean you
break your power you get off this nation
i demand judgment on you i'll be mad
his brother his son must suck
he's not even trying to stop the whole
[Music]
he's like the son-in-law where you're
like you begrudgingly tag him along
because your sister is with them but you
don't really like him
backstage he's like damn it you didn't
sell that right
our tithing's down damn but you [ __ ]
it all up slaps him
spits on him oh he's such a douche
copelan has the power to blow covert
away
all right let's see it covet 19.
19.
whoa dude that don't you just spray you
just gave everybody covered
you just that's not helpful bro
that's exactly what you're not supposed
to do and it wasn't just a blow it was
like a juicy spit
he like misted it out oh my god
oh i'm telling you it gets hot down
there i mean
like jesse says it's africa hot down
there man what is he saying
the [ __ ] you saying yeah you've been
speaking in tongues
they got down there
and that's what it takes to kill this
thing it hates heat
shut up dumbass [ __ ] con douche
yeah i mean this is the same science
this is the same guy that would take
money from someone dying of cancer
he's saying hey you know wasn't it his
ministry that was ordered by the
fda to stop selling some miracle cure
for kovid
oh no uh
another one of these guys these guys are
the best and the homeless he was selling
silver solution which they said this
kills
every virus now we haven't tested it on
covet but it kills every other virus
so it kills covet
he claims it's just a weak strain of the
flu he's here with all the greatest hits
this is on the back
of a clorox cleaning
solution right here say what
human coronavirus influenza a2
hey bro are you literally sighting the
back of a
clorox box i
this is i mean some people said you
should just drink bleach
i'm just [ __ ] i'm just a president
wait
this guy shows bible verses it's showing
the back of a clorox bottle hey guys
this thing's been around long time it's
a very
weak strain of sleep it is so weak that
the symptoms are so light
that that some people had it didn't even
know it
well they just haven't found the way to
knock that thing bro stay in your
[ __ ] lane whatever that is
so his his evidence that it's weak is
that clorox has coronavirus on the back
even though this is a different variant
of the coronavirus it's called
19 dumb [ __ ] there's more than one type
of coronavirus
god you're dumb it's copeland brand you
could buy a brain
at least with all the anyway i this i'm
just [ __ ] on him now
he used to he first wanted to be a movie
star
huh again the
he has a lot in common with the
who's the scientology guy l ron hubbard
yeah elrond hubbard
wanted to be a writer and a movie star
and all this [ __ ] you know it's all part
of the same
personality disorder whatever the [ __ ]
he's got
it's got these delusions of grandeur
[Music]
it's a christian film by the way
actually
i'll bind you satan the
name of jesus i by
you have not done your tithing sir out
of
my way
i have to say this shit's pretty badass
[Music]
laser not this time [ __ ]
watch this [ __ ] jesus christ
we love you god
how does sci-fi work with christians
this
and then he blows his head off which is
super weird
see you through and get on your knees in
the presence of the prophet
god get on your knees and suck my
dick i receive you lord jesus
i received he didn't get on his knees
now don't forget to do your tithing
what is this armor of light man they
keep coming
commander wait he's been super kids this
is a dangerous mission
but i knew my covenant brother would
come is everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
i mean it's just the same i love puppy
and if i can't handle this he's just
more recent bangers he's still at it
the rally the rally l.a
i need you to come to the house no he's
a godfather
quickly yeah he's like an ex-criminal
he's trying to change his ways that's
bendy's family
he's trying to do a godfather voice he's
coming into my podcast
and trying to talk about father fights
that's respect
we say people do
what a word
oh [ __ ] has really got that hip hop in
there
[Music]
the winds that are changing we need to
be watchful bro shouldn't you be helping
with homelessness
[Music]
what i actually have some personal
experience with this i think eric
roberts um
is in a lot of debt it's sort of like
okay i wonder if we could get him yeah
we absolutely can i worked on a short
film with him give me a price
it's his day rate as of like three or
four years ago was a thousand a day
no show up to anything
well clearly yeah yeah that's awesome
i like to just get a like menu of like
cheapest celebrities david's
i was in a day that's like a [ __ ]
that's like a
i mean a good director gets a thousand
dollars a day or like a decent director
like
anyway i will not hesitate to silence
you i will take
you out
he is coming so soon
sooner than any of us
there is no power
on this earth why didn't even china do
an accent
he doesn't blink bro this guy would win
against shoe nice for christ's sake and
a noble contest
so is this it we did it amazing
how dare he come into my house and try a
godfather accent i am the godpapa
i'm shocked kind of but especially with
the stuff
let me ask you do you do your tithing
i do no no no no no this is different
taxing is for the government this is for
god do you give ten
percent at least go back somewhere no no
no no this goes back to
god you can pay for roads and government
is not your source
jesus is your source
you gotta do the marinade at
temperatures like the mirror in there
you wanted to do the spaghetti with the
meatball without any meal now
[Laughter]
forget about it huh
and there's an email in your email that
says you were right about tarantino dan
don't worry [ __ ]
i'm blocking this person
[Laughter]
hey dan i emailed you seven months ago
during the keemstar drama
oh i'm a big fan of tarantino my email's
out loud
the logic that death proof doesn't count
because it's part of grindhouse is
nonsensical excuse me max
as you yourself said on death proof is
one of two shut up
max i gotta say ethan you get so
passionate into the arguing and honestly
dan gets dragged into history you're
both kind of like
really passionate well it turns out i
was right but i my argument was wrong i
think
what are we talking about we're talking
about kenneth copeland this is not a
podcast this is a closer look
max i'm just blocking max don't try to
email dan again i blocked you
i'm just kidding thank you then
all right well i hope that was
entertaining let me know what you guys
think i think i like this format better
than console card it's just more loose
and open
formatted and it's just not the content
card thing is come on
um that was a lot of information i
what were you impressed yeah i mean we
really got him right
yeah yeah ab and the guys did some good
ground work there send that to hbo
if you're documentarian out there i'll
find you
hallelujah can you make a film for like
i don't know a thousand bucks
we'll get eric roberts to harry roberts
who's that the actually we've just
talked about it
he'll do it narrate it right well i
think he needs help i don't think he can
produce it himself you guys
figure it out all right so today
so this comes out and then we'll be here
on friday no we will not we have
we'll be here on thursday thursday yeah
oh yeah
thursday so wait today's tuesday so this
should be out on wednesday
okay and then after dark is on thursday
because something's happening on friday
i don't know if you
are you talking about we already talked
about so is going to get her genitals
scraped
i don't know no
you're i have a procedure it's
yeah anyway it's not a big deal well i
don't want people to think it's worse
than it is they're
removing it's polyps from your
whatever okay you have a doctor's
appointment yeah
well like you made it sound already the
worst way possible no it's just normal
[ __ ] we're trying it's stuff for
for helping getting pregnant we already
talked so that's on friday so we're
moving after
thursday so let's get them so we're
doing tuesday wednesday thursday
let's get after it nice
oh jesus jesus
so in short kenneth copeland's a dude
she's a con man that's a call
yada yada 10 so i'm just saying 10
is the least i could ask if you guys
would just give me 10
of everything you make including you
guys by the way who i pay i want 10
percent back
it's awesome all right hope you guys
enjoyed we'll see you
nice when we see you whenever that is
okay
god
ass
bless